no a la hegemonía militar el gigante
asiático Pide a Estados Unidos atenerse
a las normas internacionales en la
defensa de su seguridad nacional según
la postura oficial china no tiene
interés en la supremacía militar pero sí
en mantener un balance multipolar que
sostenga una competencia sana y segura
en el mundo
ya existen normas pertinentes en el
derecho internacional relativas a las
aeronaves civiles y Estados Unidos ha
hecho caso omiso de derecho y las
prácticas internacionales al reaccionar
de forma exagerada para derribar las
aeronaves civiles no tripuladas de China
la parte estadounidense no está
capacitada para hablar de establecer
normas globales comunes sino que
deberían atenerse al derecho y a la
práctica internacional
las tensiones subieron en los últimos
días con el derribo de un supuesto globo
de espionaje Chino y otros objetos
voladores ambas superpotencias se saben
Rivales en el terreno económico pero la
competencia directa en el ámbito militar
es todavía un terreno inexplorado en sus
relaciones algunos expertos advierten un
posible aumento en las tensiones
con el incidente de los Globos empezamos
a ver una escalada y tal vez un giro en
las relaciones entre Estados Unidos y
China pasaron de ser una competencia
estratégica en el ámbito económico a una
competencia estratégica en el ámbito
militar y de seguridad nacional
la creciente afirmación de China como
potencia global y los esfuerzos de
Estados Unidos por contenerla dejan
interrogantes un evento al conflicto
armado Podría tener fuertes
consecuencias si se tiene en cuenta la
alta interacción del gigante asiático
con la economía global